[Musik]
mein name ist abmarsch arbeit alles
gewohnte reiniger ich bin ja nicht buch
harry potter reiniger mit leib und seele
bin ich dabei mein name ist ingrid
buchholz ich bin seit acht jahren firma
clean servicepower tätig als
bereichsleiter als gebäude während man
glasreinigung fassadenreinigung grafite
der beim polieren reinigung und
schädlingsbekämpfung das sind so die
hauptthemen bei der gebäudereinigung
gibt es verschiedene aufgaben zum
beispiel die unterhaltsreinigung
reinigungskräfte putzen büros saugen
böden und machen die sanitäranlagen
sauber
die gebäudereiniger haben meist
speziellere aufgaben
sie reinigen glasfassaden entfernen
graffitis
und soll man teppiche sie benutzten
spezielle maschinen und reinigungsmittel
mehr über den beruf des gebäudereinigers
erfahrt ihr im nächsten teil